I heard you had to leave in a hurry
it's never easy these days
so what are you going to do we have
unfinished business we have to go back
to where it all started
and lucky us
one thing's for sure gonna be a hell of
a reunion
still fits!
Family back together again you got fat
welcome back everyone is Charlie this is
going to be my new Black Widow trailer
video for taskmaster everyone wondering
who that character is Red Hulk in
Thunderbolts post Avengers end game so
we'll break it all down there's a whole
bunch of Easter eggs if you're new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get
everything we're doing a Marvel giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave your best theory
about who taskmaster is on the video
what I'll do is I'll start with the
taskmaster stuff then I'll talk about
Thunderbolts post-credit scenes and Red
Hulk stuff in the future of the MCU when
I released my last big black widow
trailer video there were a lot of
theories that you guys had about who
taskmaster was but they're pretty clear
on the timeline of taskmaster during
this trailer we see him use a bow just
like Hawkeye a lot of people wondering
if maybe he's going to secretly be
Hawkeye I don't think that's the case
you have to remember that characters big
thing is stealing other people's moves
literally taking their moves and copying
them so the reason why he's so good with
a bow is probably because he fought
Hawkeye some time in the past and stole
his moves the big twist theory that
everyone has about taskmaster is that
it'll wind up being someone who was part
of black widows
alternative family when she was part of
the Red Room program her family of the
past the other early big theory people
had is the taskmaster will wind up being
a female character instead of a male
like the comics so in the comics
taskmaster is a man he's a completely
separate character that has no real
connection with the Avengers winds up
becoming something of a mercenary then
turns into an Avengers villain for a
long time but addressing the taskmaster
as female theory using this scene at the
end of the movie with taskmaster vs. Red
Guardian as an example you see them
bum-rushing each other so look at David
Harbor giant bear like Russian version
of Captain America he's sort of like the
dragon ball fusion of the thick version
of Thor in Captain America
make all the jokes you want about that
but in real life David Harbor is 6 foot
3 so he's huge but as they joke he got
fat meaning back in the 90s probably
when he was in his prime he was way more
cut like Captain America you look at
this scene
taskmaster is way way slimmer in the
neck and shoulder armor that they're
wearing is bigger to obscure their upper
body shape and it does make it harder to
tell if it really is a man or a woman
they do that on purpose so you can't
easily guess who the character is when I
post
my last big trailer video there were
people that thought the taskmaster might
be Rachel vices character because you
don't really see her during a large
portion of the trailer but think about
it this way
they're all standing here at comic-con
next to each other she's only five foot
six
David Harbor standing next to her sort
of kissing the top of her head here
she's also wearing heels in this too so
barefoot standing next to each other
she's tiny compared to David Harbor so
when taskmaster and Red Guardian are
fighting inside this evil version of The
Avengers base in Siberia rush I'm
assuming that this is where the Red Room
program is that they're trying to
destroy both of them are equally hunched
down as they wind up for huge punches in
taskmaster isn't that much shorter than
David Harper implying that it's someone
who's way way taller in real life than
Rachel Feist so if it is a female
character it'd be a really really tall
female character the other problem is
you have to look at the other footage of
taskmaster during the trailer so there's
the scene of taskmaster chasing down
Black Widow and Yelena biloba in
Budapest in their version of present-day
post-civil war he pulls the bow out he's
driving that giant tank all the stuff
with them having their family meal
together in the white uniforms with
David Harper joking about his costume
still fitting look it still fits but
look how fat you got that's also
happening in the present day after she
sort of rounds the team up and that
starts with her in Budapest going to
pick up Yelena Belova they put those
white suits on then you see them at the
end of the trailer trying to blow up
this version of the Red Room program in
Siberia Russia during that is where you
see red Guardian fighting taskmaster so
it wouldn't be possible for Rachel vices
character to be the taskmaster character
it would have to be somebody completely
different that appears nowhere in the
trailer footage that doesn't mean that
it's not somebody that we don't already
know and it's going to be some big twist it
just means the taskmaster isn't any of
the other characters that you see during
the trailer there were people also
asking if taskmaster was going to be
Hawkeye
the reason why taskmaster can't be
Hawkeye is because this scene of him in
the tank is after the events of Civil
War and Hawkeye was on his farm with his
family for that entire period post-civil
war right up into the snap at the end of
Avengers infinity war that's when he
took the mantle of Ronin and went on
that rampage going after all the
criminals that survived the snap I do
think that Hawkeye has a cameo in
but I think it's a further flashback to
Budapest before the events of Iron Man 2
when he was technically sent to destroy her
but instead shows her mercy officer a
better option joined shield and get some
of that read off your ledger that's a
moment that they referenced right before
she sacrifices herself during avengers
endgame when they had that conversation
about not judging someone based on their
past mistakes Hawkeye was talking about
himself the black widow says you didn't
either talking about their time in
Budapest which is presumably a further
flashback before Iron Man 2 early
guesses there'll be a moment at some
point at the end of the film either a
mid-credits scene where Nick Fury shows
up and then gives her her first mission
which is to spy on Iron Man during Iron
Man 2 but talking about Thunderbolt Ross
Red Hulk Thunderbolt setup in the new
version of Black Widow Yelena Belova you
all have your post credit scene theories
this movie is a Marvel phase 4 movie
meaning that at some point during the
movie probably the post credits scene
there'll be a moment that addresses
what's going on in the future post
Avengers endgame because that's
happening at 2023 and most of this movie
takes place in the past post Civil War
so at some point they will have to jump
back and connect things to what's going
on in present-day Marvel and Kevin Feige
have said several times in the past
they've discussed doing Thunderbolts at
some point they never really said
whether it would be a series on Disney
Plus or if it'd be a big movie but if
you haven't read those comics it's
basically Marvel's version of a Suicide
Squad team a bunch of the worst comic
book villains that get locked up the
Thunderbolt Ross then offers an option
will wipe your criminal history if you
help us out on this mission that will
probably wind up destroying you and if you die it's no big sweat to us because
you're criminals over the past couple of
years they've accumulated a number of
villains who were on that comic book
version of the team Baron Zemo being one
of the former leaders and he's going to be
showing up during Falcon and Winter
Soldier next year this time next year
we'll actually be watching those Falcon
Winter Soldier episodes we already have
Thunderbolt Ross we know that he
survived the snaps so he's alive in
present-day post Avengers endgame he's
the one that originally created the team
that's why it's called Thunderbolts
early theory is is that Black Widow is
able to save Yelena Belova at the end of
the movie but after the events of
Avengers endgame
Black Widow as we know her Natasha is
dead in Thunderbolt
is left with a hole in his roster of
agents who were good at spy craft covert
ops things that Black Widow used to do
for him so the idea is that Yelena
Belova survives into post endgame
present day and Thunderbolt Ross makes
her an offer she can't refuse in a twist
on a Nick Fury iron man post credit
scene he came to recruit iron man for
two The Avengers and start setting that
up at the beginning of phase 1 so
because this is the beginning of phase 4
wouldn't it be a great twist if
Thunderbolt Ross has a twist on that
moment setting up a Thunderbolts project in the future of phase 4 and phase 5
hopefully they don't kill taskmaster off
to and that person can wind up joining
the Thunderbolts team in the future but
addressing the Red Hulk of it all so if
you didn't see it I did a video about
the Red Hulk deleted scene from Avengers
endgame Marvel in the writers for
Avengers endgame originally planned to
turn the Bruce Banner Hulk into Red Hulk
during endgame no joke is just as crazy
as it sounds what they were going to do
is the writer said is that the cosmic
stresses on his body would have turned
him red while he was trying to snap the
Nano Infinity Gauntlet and that was
going to be their MCU version of Red Hulk
ultimately they cut that out of the
movie because they decided it would have
been too confusing just like they didn't
do grey Hulk during Avengers age of
Ultron like they originally planned to
saving those things those big twist for
Hoek characters for future movies so if
there's a future for the Thunderbolts
inside the MCU and it's a twist on the
passing of torches like passing the
torch of Black Widow to the Yelena
Belova Black Widow and William Hurt
himself is a huge Hulk comic book fan he
said that was his main reason for
signing his original contract with
Marvel to be Thunderbolt Ross of the MCU
so everyone let me know in the comments do you want them to do Red Hulk at some
point and do you want them to do a
Thunderbolts project there's a whole
bunch of stuff coming up so as long as
you have alerts enabled for my channel
you should see the videos when I post
them but leave all your Marvel video
requests in the comments below
everyone click here for my last really
big Black Widow trailer video and click
here for my brand new Mandalorian Episode 6
video thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight!